okay now I know a lot of you were gonna
read the title and you're gonna freak
out and you're like how could you watch
the video and try to understand what I'm
saying
so if you hadn't heard jenna Marbles
basically cancelled herself last week
she did but it's like cancel culture is
it's so strong you got people out there
canceling there's a tsunami waiver like
I'm not gonna make it to shore so jenna
Marbles if you aren't aware is one of
the og youtubers she's been on platform
for over ten years doing it at a high
level and recently videos from 2010-2012
resurfaced on different platforms where
they alleged that she did blackface and
did all the other kinds of stuff I don't
think I'm having a good time and it
seems like maybe some other people
aren't having a good time so for now I
don't
I just can't exist on this channel and
so now they they have been educated in
the truth of jenna Marbles she's been
cancelled she's been handled thank you
to mob mentality Twitter shout-out to
you for you have tweeted the truth now
jenna Marbles is the is part of the
reason why jenna Marbles got canceled
and I tried to make fun content
inclusive content things that don't
offend people or upset people because I
just don't want anyone to feel upset
about anything I don't want someone to
watch something feel hurt or offended
now for any reason all that matters is
that people are offended and it hurt
them but I do want to tell you how
unbelievably sorry I am if I ever
offended you I don't have anyone this
attitude that's become pervasive in our
society is the problem because people
feel entitled to never being offended -
never seen anything offensive they see
something that they deem is offensive
and therefore feel like their outrage is
justified they feel like their mob
mentality is justified they have this on
college campuses where they have safe
spaces and trigger warnings it's one
thing to create a space that's safe from
any kind of physical attack and you know
unwanted events I understand that but
hearing ideas that differ from your own
or hearing Hueber that you don't
is for you and then you thinking you
deserve the right to then cancel people
is the problem
and so when jenna gets there and she
says I don't try to make content that
hurt nobody
I don't think anybody should be hurt by
what that's the problem in trying to
make everyone's sensitivities feel like
it's acceptable
we've created a soft society where
anything can be deemed offensive and
what ends up happening even you who try
to make content for everyone ends up
being cancelled by everyone here's the
reality
go ahead when we when we tell college
and young people that they don't deserve
to be offended they grew up to be weaker
adults because they grow up to think
that the world is meant to be this one
hundred percent acceptable place where
we all drive on the same ideas but
that's not the reality of the world and
especially if you leave your country are
gonna realize that people's values and
morals are completely different and if
you go around in a multicultural place
like North America where all these
cultures mixed from all different parts
of the world and you're offended by
differences of opinion and different
humor then you are for sure going to be
someone who can't navigate this world as
a functioning adult and that's what's
happening on college campuses
we literally have spaces right now where
people have to put trigger warnings
before most things we're comedians who
go on college campuses have to avoid so
many topics and sign waivers because
people can't handle humor what kind of
young people are we breathing what we're
telling them that the world is supposed
to be a safe place what's going to be
happy when they're gonna encounter
danger that they can't control they're
gonna break down what happens when
they're gonna encounter
ideas that are better than them but that
hurts their feelings they're gonna break
down they're gonna start shaking but
when you say I don't want to make
content that offends anybody it's
equivalent to saying we should no longer
have rented our movies because kids
could watch it [ __ ] if you sensitive
stay off that's your problem not mine a
lot of people should stay off the
internet because they're way too
sensitive ruff if you ask me
yeah the other day I was I was someone
dropped in my DMS saying like oh yeah
you guys are amazing
cool next day I guess a couple of days
after that that person went oh no you're
not amazing you guys ate first I'm like
what why did you laugh at entrances to
intersectionality like that
but it's not because we laugh that we
hate you the parallel that she did
because we laugh at something we hated
so when I make fun of my sister I hate
her
right yeah when I having fun in family
with my parents that we just well my mom
makes one she hates me is that what it
is
so when you make fun of something you
ultimately hate it we can laugh and
that's what I told I'm not y'all we
laugh at everything and anything and
that's what equality is period that's
what it is
feel free to come feel free to Spain or
to leave but that's what we do you laugh
at anything
and I sympathize with Jenna in this
respect I understand that she's trying
to do the right thing I understand that
she's well-intentioned but it's not
because you're well-intentioned that
you're necessarily doing the right thing
that's also something that people have
to acknowledge your good intentions
aren't actually good think about what
kind of message you're sending to the
world when you cancel yourself for
things that one happened to pass to
people misrepresented you want because
apparently it wasn't blackface she was
just severely tan because she took off
her wig yeah okay to do blackface
this is the end of the video where I
took my wig off I I don't know how else
to say this stop apologizing stop
because when you apologize you send out
the message to the world that you
weren't Herrin tear awn and they were
right and unless you did something that
was really wrong do not apologize
because now you're setting new standards
and you're embolden in those people the
majority of people watch their content
most of the world have no problem with
it
but the fact that you cow tail and into
this small minority emboldened them and
it makes them all of a sudden you got
news headlines where it's like the world
is angry no it's not the world it's a
couple of goofballs on Twitter who feel
emboldened and that's all it is stop a
part and here's a third thing stop
apologizing to moms that's a waste of
your time
have you ever seen a mob trying to chase
someone down and beat them down in the
purse like I'm sorry and they stopped no
they never do they never do wait two
weeks everything blows over because mobs
they're not that strong okay they don't
have stamina
Bob don't have that there you go good
day my pan-african brothers and sisters
today we have on trial a girl whose vile
color jenna Marbles cuz she's lost her
marbles she got on screen and did the
deed where she said things in blackface
while having a white face in reality of
people who hate you you are hateable
preach we will say the truth
this is preach Malcolm the third about
May day day day same the truth that day
day day need to hear huh you say the
truth huh you say the truth huh you say
the truth huh you say the truth now sing
it sing it sing it the truth you say the
truth huh you say the truth
ha you say the truth white supremacy the
that's a good song
things change as a matter of fact we
here at the Aven preach channel we are
if we haven't offended you yet it's
coming if it's coming it's not something
that we can change or we could do
something about there's gonna be
something that we're gonna say
eventually and it's gonna rub you the
wrong way now it's gonna be for you to
decide how you want to go about things I
understand that what we're doing is
jokes or just let it go or being
offended - it's not because you're
offended that's your right comedy is the
thing that ages that doesn't age well it
doesn't age well so the minute you
trying to make someone laugh in six
months in a year form that down the line
it might not be relevant anymore or it
might just be offensive because we can't
laugh at it according to whoever breath
I'm already done stuff that should have
me canceled the only difference I didn't
do it on camera
absolutely difference is that Wheatley
yeah yeah we you know miss it four years
ago so imagine we started doing this
[ __ ] ten years ago there would have been
food stuff oh this is why YouTube is
also going downhill the people think
that they can love on this platform and
just not see offensive ideas all the
time like why this is the problem with
our society well people think they can
walk around and never be offended I'm
like you guys live in such a point of
privilege that you think that you can
still create art and make some that will
offend nobody let me do a revolution and
not offend nobody yeah let me do
something totally revolutionary but not
offend nobody [ __ ] you can't
even see women nipples on Instagram or
Facebook
have you seen safeSpace comedy oh you
know what it's like it's like getting to
the bathroom and wanting to take a dump
but no poop comes out so you're just mad
because you have to take your pants sit
down paper or the whole bowl touch the
toilet bowl sit down and then nothing
comes out just farts that's insulting
that's what that's what's a space comedy
is very seen people who will get on this
castle culture train are the same people
who will advocate for police reform or
prison reform and they're basically
fighting for the ability to rehabilitate
criminals right understanding that the
past is the past and we should give
people a second chance so let me get
this straight you want to give second
chances to criminals people who've
served their time and I agree with you
but then when it comes to individuals
who do nothing illegal go do something
in the past who have changed their ways
rehabilitation is not a thing they need
to be punished do you believe in our
form or you don't
hmm what is it which one is it's a
rehabilitation do you believe we're me
happy like it's like looking at an
addict and be like you're not savable
yeah you know my criminal you're not
savable
but defunding the police is what it is
we have the rehabilitation of the system
down second chances are the hallmark of
any advanced society pretty much and
they turn on everyone so even in your
effort to not you're going to get turned
on I promise you they will come for you
eventually and then you're gonna wish
that second chances were a real thing
concept just uh you know it's just uh
there's no way you're gonna be favored
there's a lot of people that you know
mmm predators they use that as you know
did you I'm the safe space now yeah I
think I made that analogy it was like
her their safe space are a breeding
ground for wolves in sheep's clothing
how many times have we seen safe spaces
go down because somebody was being a
predator in there hey good day my [ __ ]
since that is all for today's video if
you've learned something from here on
Hideo keep watching keep talking keep
listening to the sounds that I make all
that [ __ ] to say listen if you liked
subscribe
Preston whether the Bell right so will
subscribe to the emancipation of black
people for we have been enslaved by the
algorithm the algorithm keeps making
analogous things true lies false that I
know change our perception for real eyes
realize what rely we've dropped bombs
but they're not over back dad they're
over your newsfeed brother we offend you
the truth that you need to heed anyways
like subscribe but do you like me or do
you like what I make the same way that
white people like black culture but
don't like black people themselves tell
me when you leave a comment are you
commenting on what we said or what you
thought we said like ghosts of the past
are we here for the present or living in
our past war for water I want some water
i'ma get some water Abba zaba Zulu clean
good day to you my brothers and me Gus
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a Twitter account right mmm
I post something and I get off I don't
browse that [ __ ] at all cuz every time I
see Twitter pose that people reposing my
what am I looking at
what is this you saw what she also
preemptively apologize for something
that people weren't trying to cancel for
her oh demanding an apology uh
for that video of me right now but I'm
like just you know what put it on my tab
here's another thing I'm sorry for it's
like throwing yourself in jail for a
crime the police haven't stopped you for
who might I'm turning myself in for what
for killing somebody they're not
reported dead they're gonna be no it was
really weird to watch that yes